the trump white house just killed
critical race theory training in federal
agencies it's the stuff that claims all
white people are racist
in this inherently racist country so
once again the big orange
meanie does something no one had the
guts to do before
eradicate a punitive ideology that ruins
businesses and lives
and it's one that you pay for a disease
born from the hateful halls of left-wing
academia
critical race theory undermines the
positive core beliefs of america
by redefining the nation as an engine of
oppression
this leads to discord in schools
families and now even work
the top attribute of a great employee
positive attitude
crt replaces that with grievance and
envy
and what you're seeing on america's city
streets are its results
starting on campus then leaking into
unconscious bias training at work
culminating in infantile rioters who use
this ideology to justify
violence you wonder why these clones
accost people at restaurants
they've been brainwashed to think you're
unconsciously racist
and they're there to wake you up
unconsciously racist
means even when you say you aren't
racist the response is
no you just aren't conscious of it
that's a cult
but those who demand such indoctrination
operate on their own
unconscious racism they assume all white
people are one way
possessing white privilege that's
conscious racism
and trump's right to expel this toxin
from the workplace
let's hope this bravery spreads the
survival of our country
depends on it
all right we'll go fast around the horn
here dana good move on trump's
part uh
possibly although i do think he's gonna
there's gonna be the pushback of course
but i think that there is not enough
people that understand
what crt is and also it comes along
this year as we've been dealing with the
1619 project that's from the new york
times
uh basically trying to redefine the
birth of america i would also say this
though
if there's not going to be crt which i
don't necessarily think there should be
crt
should there be better historical
education in our k-12
schools and even in college because i
think over and over again
we are trying as people here on the five
to explain to our viewers who are
already probably
pretty well informed about our nation's
history
and that that kind of knowledge has to
be
re-examined the civics education in our
country the historic
historic history education in our
country absolutely has to be something
that we deal with now that's not
something the president can deal with
schools are
run by local school districts and they
should be but i think that without
understanding and learning our history
we are going to be in a pretty tough
situation like we are this summer
you know emily uh i think that crt is
probably one of the worst things that
has ever
been invented in my life and that it it
creates an attitude that replaces
optimism
and and desire for opportunity with
grievance and
envy why would anybody want to hire
somebody like that
and trying to apply it to the federal
government is such a farce greg
it's like it's trying to apply someone's
individual paradigm
to something that is not a like beast
take it from me i was a federal managing
attorney for years and i know what
resource utilization looks like
it would be a colossal waste of time and
waste of taxpayer dollars
and by the way in a huge study conducted
of our mammoth federal government
the 80 and 90 plus percentage of
employees what they really want training
and what they really think would benefit
us as citizens
are things like technology innovation
and reducing security and privacy
requirements
and things that would actually make a
difference in how our government
runs and how we seize those benefits we
see those benefits
not this sort of fantasyland stuff
you know jesse even liberals like this
because they saw crt
undermining the soft and hard sciences
in academia
they started to infect everything with
this ideology of race
greg i'd like to say something on behalf
of white people right now dana hold my
hand
oh god no god no no no no no i'm scared
that was a test it was a joke i was just
seeing if dana was paying attention
i didn't have anything to say but good
dana you stopped me i felt the squeeze
good job
listen greg um i feel enough guilt just
being jesse waters i don't
need additional a lot of this has to do
with money and power
the people that run these little
seminars they're mostly radical social
justice warrior lawyers
you pay them to do the survey and then
it inculcates you from lawsuits later
it's also a good way if you want to to
get people
fired or promoted with things that have
nothing to do with work
product my problem is
that you're dead right on that project
my problem with the 1619 project is it's
narrow focus
uh you know i'm over 10 native american
that means that
10 of my descendants were here thousands
of years before 1619.
latinos are the biggest minority group
in this country native americans have to
be recognized as well
uh you know we have this this
this laser focus this narrow focus on
a minority that has been oppressed and
and justly
needs recognition for that oppression
and discrimination so do other groups as
well
and the best way to do that is with
everybody
integrating together not separating